let's say there's an election coming up
and I want to figure out if there's a
meaningful difference between the
proportion of men and the proportion of
women that are going to vote for
candidate so let's look at the
population distributions here so we have
the men and the men some proportion are
going to vote for the candidate we'll
call that P one so this is the
proportion that will vote for the
candidate and the rest of the men will
not vote for the candidate so 1 minus P
1 will not vote for the candidate and
then for the women you're going to see
something similar so this is the women
right over here and some proportion will
vote for the candidate we don't know if
it's the same as P 1 we don't know if
it's same as the men so we'll call it P
2 and then the rest of the women will
not vote for the candidate 1 minus P 2
so the not voting our zeroes the ones
that are voting are ones and those are
these are both Bernoulli distributions
and we know just because this will be
useful later on we know that the means
of this distribution are the same as the
proportion that will vote for it so you
can the mean the mean of the men or the
proportion of the men that will vote so
we'll call that mean 1 is equal to P 1
and the variance here the variance here
the variance of this first distribution
I should do everything in yellow
actually do everything in yellow so the
mean of this distribution the mean of
this distribution is P 1 the variance of
this distribution will call that
variance 1 is just these two
probabilities multiple or these two
proportions multiplied by each other so
it's P 1 times 1 minus P 1 and we saw
this many many videos ago when we
learned about Bernoulli distributions
and we're going to see the exact same
thing with the women the mean of this
Bernoulli distribution is going to be P
2 and then the variance of this
Bernoulli distribution the variance of
this Bernoulli distribution is going to
be these two proportions multiplied so P
2 times 1 minus P 2 now what I want to
do and I think I said this at the
beginning of the video is I want to
figure out if there's a meaningful
difference between the way that the men
will vote and the women will vote I want
to figure out
I want to figure out is this different
is let me write this is this is this
meaningful so is there a meaningful
distant difference here and what we're
going to do in this video is try to come
up with a 95% confidence interval for
this parameter this difference of
parameters is still a parameter we don't
know what the true difference of these
two population parameters are but we can
or these two population proportions but
we're going to try to come up with a 95%
95% confidence confidence interval
interval for for that difference and the
way we do that we go out and we find a
thousand likely men to vote or men
likely to vote in a thousand women
likely to vote so let's write this down
so we get a thousand men when we survey
the thousand men let's say six hundred
and forty to say that they will vote for
the candidate so they are ones and then
the remainder we can even it would be
three hundred and fifty-eight well just
say the remainder so the rest are zeros
and we do the same thing with women we
survey 1000 women who are likely to vote
but we surveyed them randomly and let's
say 591 say that they will vote for the
candidate and the rest say that they
will not vote for the candidate will not
vote for the candidate so just here
based on our sample proportions our
sample means it looks like there is a
difference but we still have to come up
with our confidence interval and let's
just make sure we understand what we
just did we just found so we could
figure out a sample proportion over here
for the men so the sample proportion
here for the men if you which is really
just the sample mean of this of this
sample right over here we have 642 ones
the rest are 0 so we have 642 in the
numerator we have a thousand samples 642
divided by a thousand is 0.6 for two so
you could view this as a sample mean or
as a sample proportion and if you do the
same thing for the women the sample
proportion is going to be 0.591
or you can even just view this as the
sample mean of the sample of a thousand
we're the ones voting for it is one the
rest are 0 and just to visualize it
properly let me draw the sampling
distribution for the sample proportion
so the sampling distribution we have a
large sample size we have a large sample
size here so we can and especially
because the proportions that we're
dealing with aren't close to 1 or 0 and
we have a large sample size the sampling
distribution will be approximately
normal
so the sampling distribution let me
write this a sampling sampling
distribution of the sample proportion so
it's going to have some mean over here
it's going to have some mean over here
so the mean of the sampling distribution
of the sample proportion and we've seen
it multiple times it's going to be the
same thing as the mean of the population
and the mean of the population is
actually the true population proportion
so this is going to be equal to P 1 this
is something that we don't know about
and then the variance of this and we've
seen this several times already
the variance of this distribution the
variance of this distribution I have to
put a 1 here we're dealing with the men
the variance of this distribution by the
central limit theorem is going to be the
variance of this distribution up here
which is P 1 times 1 minus P 1 over our
sample size over 1,000 and we can do the
exact same thing for the women the exact
same thing for the women so this is the
sampling distribution let me write it
over here this is the sampling
distribution this is for P 2 bar or the
this sample mean over here let me put a
1 over here to remember this is for them
this is for all for the men and then
this over here is all for the women
can't forget those twos over there and
so this distribution is going to have
some mean this distribution is going to
have some mean let me draw it right over
here so mu sub P 2 with a bar over it so
the mean of the sampling distribution
for this sample proportion for the women
we
is going to be the same thing as the
mean of the population which we already
saw is going to be equal to p2 and then
the variance the variance for this
distribution for this sampling
distribution over here is going to be p2
is going to be this variance this
variance over here divided by our sample
size so P 2 times 1 minus P 2 all of
that over n now our whole goal is to get
a 95% confidence interval for that and
so what we're going to do is we're going
to think about the sampling distribution
not for this and not the sampling
distribution for this but we're going to
think about the sampling distribution
for the difference of this sample this
sample proportion and this sample
proportion we've seen it already this is
really you know we're talking about
proportions but it's really the same
exact ideas that we did when we were
just compared sample means generally so
let's look at that let's look at that
distribution let's look at this
distribution and just to be clear when
we when we got when we got this sample
mean here this sample proportion we just
sampled it you could view it as taking a
sample from this distribution over here
when we got this sample proportion it
was like taking a sample from this over
here
we took 591 or we took a thousand
samples from this when we took their
mean where it's equivalent to taking a
sample from the sampling distribution
now this district this to shoot this
distribution over here is going to be
the distribution of all the differences
of the sampling proportions or of the
sample proportions and so it will look
like this it will look like this it will
have some mean value I should do this in
a different color I'll do it in green
yellow and blue make green let me do
this one in green so I'll call this the
sampling distribution this is the
sampling distribution of this statistic
of p1 minus p2 and so it has some mean
over here
it has some mean the mean of the sample
of p1 minus the sample mean or the
sample proportion of p2 and we know from
things that we've done
the last several videos that this is
going to be the exact same thing as this
mean minus this mean which is the exact
same thing as the p1 minus p2 so this is
going to be equal to p1 minus p2 p1
minus p2 and the variance of this
distribution the variance of this
distribution so the variance of this
distribution p1 let me write it p1 minus
p2 just like this is going to be the sum
of the variances of these two
distributions so it's going to be this
thing over here I'll just copy and paste
it copy and paste it's going to be that
thing over there plus this variance over
here there's no radical sign because
we're not taking the standard deviation
we're focused on the variance right now
so Plus this thing right over here so
let me copy and let me paste it so Plus
this thing right over here so that's
going to be the variance this is going
to be the variance and if you want the
standard deviation if you want the
standard deviation you can literally
just get rid of this you're taking the
square square root of both sides so you
take the square root of the variance you
get the standard deviation that's why I
got rid of that to the second power and
you want to take a square root of the
right hand side just like that now all I
did right now just to kind of
conceptually set things up in our brain
what we now need to do is actually
tackle the confidence interval we
actually need to come up with a 95%
confidence interval for p1 minus p2 or a
95% confidence interval for this mean
right over here and because I'm trying
to make my best effort not to make
videos too long I'll do part two in the
next video where we actually solve the
confidence interval